the moons of Mars explained Mars has two
moons Phobos and Deimos they are really
tiny how tiny compared to Mars or our
own Moon pretty tiny
although tiny is a matter of opinion
their surface areas are close to some of
the smallest states on earth like
Luxembourg and Malta although Phobos and
Deimos are in no way lightweights in
reality their gravitational pull isn't
even strong enough to bring them into
spherical form so they look more like
huge potatoes than moons
the most popular theory of their origin
is that they were once part of the
asteroid belt until Jupiter's massive
gravity kicked them out of it so Mars
could catch them Phobos orbits Mars as
an average distance of nine thousand
four hundred kilometers once every seven
and a half hours it's on a collision
course and gets two meters close to Mars
every year in 50 to 100 million years it
will either be ripped to pieces by
Mars's gravity and be transformed into a
beautiful ring or it will crash into
Mars the energy released in this
collision would kill everything on the
small planet so if there are humans on
Mars by then they should build very
strong bunkers smaller Deimos on the
other hand is slowly escaping Mars
eventually it will fly off into space
and leave a lonely red planet behind so
in a few hundred million years Mars will
be moonless and on its own
unless it manages to catch itself
another asteroid
[Music]